- Here's a tip for remembering
which amendments to the
constitution do what,
specifically the prohibition amendments.
Now I will never forget
which amendment does what,
what institutes prohibition
and what repeals prohibition,
because I have a mnemonic.
Specifically, I know that the amendment
that created prohibition
was the 18th amendment
because 18 years old used to
be the drinking age in America
but it's not any more.
So that is what got rid of drinking.
And I know that the 21st amendment
is the one that repealed prohibition
because that is the current
drinking age in America.
So now you know and you will never forget
which amendment does what
with respect to prohibition
and drinking in America.